so today we're building this sort of diy
pet cam for tracking what your pets do
while you're gone
whether you want to know whether your
dog's hanging out on the couch or your
chickens are trespassing on the porch or
your cat's just doing some casual
software development while you're gone
we'll build an app that runs a machine
learning model on your phone to detect
events like
dog on couch and then sends you a
notification on slack
it'll also save snapshots of those
moments to the cloud so let's get to it
and build an ml-powered petcam that runs
on your smartphone
[Music]
one of the cool things about this
project is that we're going to do the
computer vision part entirely in a web
app that can run
on a smartphone it'll be privacy
conscious so we'll only send a
notification or save a picture to the
cloud when your pet does something that
you care about
otherwise your video and your photos
will stay entirely on your local device
i'm building this petcam with my
colleague jason mays a developer
advocate and host of the youtube show
made with tensorflow.js
hey jason thanks for having me dell you
know we've got a ton of old devices like
smartphones
just sitting around doing absolutely
nothing so i really wanted to think
about how we can give those a new life
in a way that anyone can then replicate
and hopefully use to do something useful
so why a pet cam yeah that's a great
question so essentially i saw a lot of
people around me these days
buying kittens and puppies and i think
it'd be quite fun to kind of
track those as they're growing up to
make sure we're not being too naughty
when you're leaving the house
when they're alone and of course you
know you can always extend this to other
objects in the future too as well
like a chicken yeah like a chicken as
well anything could be possible
all right let's do it okay so our app's
gonna work like this
first we'll build a pet tracking camera
app that runs on your phone and detects
common pets like cats and dogs
then we'll make our app tracker even
more powerful by training a custom pet
model on google cloud
to detect chickens and finally we'll
connect our front end to a back end
built in firebase so that we can store
data and send messages to slack
okay so let's talk about the actual
front-end application
that tracks animals the first step is to
enable the webcam access
and load a tensorflow.js model for
object detection
today we'll use the coco ssd model that
recognizes 80 common household objects
in any picture that you pass to it now
importing tensorflow.js
and the machine learning model is
actually really simple
first you've got two script tag imports
for tensorflow.js and the model itself
next we can grab a reference to the
video object that we're rendering our
webcam to
and once we've got that we can call
cocosd.load we can then call
model.detect
and pass it the video element on our
webpage to classify the current frame
being played from our webcam so once we
can detect what's in a given video frame
we then need to send an alert when the
pet in this example a dog
gets close to an object that we care
about such as a food bowl
couch or bed here we simply allow the
user to choose from the objects the
model can recognize
to make their selection as shown and we
ask the user to ensure the device is set
up
in front of the object we want to
monitor once enabled
then when we've detected that the user
has placed the device in view of the
object they want to monitor
we can continuously check the video
stream to see if a chosen pet ever gets
close to that object
to do that we calculated the distance
between their bounding boxes
if the distance is less than some
threshold we'll send an alert to a back
end to then send a notification
now we also had to add some logic to
avoid spamming the user with too many
notifications in case the dog came in
and out of frame continuously
which you can learn all about over in
our blog posts so check the link in the
description after
and that's essentially how the front end
works if you want to play this yourself
and grab the code
you can find it over on glitch.com as
shown so after jason built the front end
we could start testing the app
but the problem was that jason and i
actually don't own any pets so we had to
get kind of creative with our testing
setups
and it also borrowed benji for corgi
from a friend to check
couch and board alerts for dogs which
caught him every single time as you can
see
it actually worked better than i
expected but then in the middle of
working on this project
i actually did acquire some pets two
baby chicks
but despite how incredibly adorable they
were our pre-built tensorflow model
didn't really recognize them
so i had to figure out a way to adopt
petcam to work for my chicks
which brings us to part two training a
custom chicken detection model
i did this using vertex ai google's new
machine learning development platform
look at these cute little data points
automl vision is a tool within the
vertex ai platform that lets you build a
vision model without writing any code
and then export it to tensorflow.js
first in the vertex ai console i created
a new image object detection data set
then i uploaded about 100 pictures of my
new baby chicks to google cloud storage
so they could be imported into vertex ai
after the data imported i opened an
image and annotated it by hand
i decided to train the model to
recognize moira and millie separately
because they're two different breeds of
chicken and i thought it would be super
cool if the model could tell them apart
i also annotated the position of their
food and water bowl so i could calculate
when the chicks were eating and drinking
then i just did this a hundred more
times and it took about 30 minutes
when i was done labeling i hit train new
model and then selected automl edge to
create a model optimized for an edge
device
i named my model selected some
configuration options
configured it to train for five node
hours and then waited
when my model was done at training i
checked out the precision and recall
in the evaluate tab and this model was
pretty accurate
to actually use it in my app go to the
deploy and test tab click tensorflow.js
and then choose a location in cloud
storage to export the model from here we
can download it and use it right in our
app's javascript front end
all right now let's connect the back end
to make this app actually useful
we want to save these pet events when
they occur and then set an alert to the
user over slack
for this i of course turn to my favorite
serverless toolkit firebase
when the front-end app detects the dog's
on the couch it saves a snapshot and
some metadata about the event to
firestore then i built a little app a
front-end
to pull data from that firestore
database and then display it as a sort
of
diary so you can keep track of all the
cute or mischievous things that your pet
is doing while you're gone
to set up slack notifications i used a
firebase cloud function to call the
slack api
it's set up with the trigger so that
when data is written to the firestore
database it automatically triggers my
firebase cloud function to run
and then send an alert and that's it
that's the whole back end
if you want to learn how to build a pet
cam yourself check out the code and the
blog post linked below
you can also check out tensorflow.js and
other primo models you can use on our
websites
and of course if you want more
inspiration check out made with tfjs
hashtags on twitter and linkedin
by the way if you want to see how my
colleague mark who built his very own
pet cam that runs on device as well
using coral then check out his take on a
very similar project here
i guess great minds just think alike or
something and if you do try this
yourself make sure you let us know in
the comments
see you next time
you